- Right.
(upbeat music)
I have never had American-made poutine.
I don't know what they think poutine is.
- People call it disco fries here
and that turns me off.
- I remember this looking better.
Smells a bit like gasoline.
Is that, should I,
should I be eating this?
- Very gelatinous.
- OK, here we go, here we go.
- The cheese curds look
like they're shredded.
- It doesn't taste awful,
but it's kinda got the texture of glue.
- This is terrible (chuckles).
- I would pay like three dollars
at the most for this, Canadian.
- I would not pay anything for this.
You would have to pay me to eat this.
(cash register)
- No.
(laughing)
- What?
- This one's got a garnish.
- This one doesn't have cheese curds.
- I don't think poutine
should have a garnish.
- I mean, there's no discernible gravy.
There's no discernible cheese curds.
- This is also terrible.
- The fries are well done, which I like.
- I'd pay three bucks for this.
(cash register)
- I mean, that's ridiculous.
Poutine is like a snack food.
- Oo, there's chunks of meat in here.
- Way too meaty.
- I feel like I'm gonna regret
learning what this was.
- The meat is great.
- Fine, hard to mess up.
Not my favorite, but you know, edible.
- If my goal is eat poutine,
this is not it.
(cash register)
- Why is poutine so expensive here?
Are they importing everything from Quebec?
It doesn't taste like it.
- This is not poutine.
- You tried, America.
I think that's the important part.
- I feel bad for my American friends
that have to try this and this is what
they think poutine is.
- This has made me a little homesick.
And a little tummy sick.
- That was a thing that happened.
Nope. (chuckles)